thank you
[Music]
I definitely didn't have to go job
hunting I didn't have to look for any
career guidance from outside simply
learns data science carried bootcamp did
it all for me I landed a job as power
beer developer in a leading media joint
simply learn helped me to Kickstart my
data science career hi I'm amaravadi
Gautam originally from Telangana working
as a power bi developer in Bangalore I
finished my masters in statistics and
competitions in 2021 I knew I like
numbers and dig out data so I had to
make a career in that I realized I need
to have a proper certification in data
science hence I chose simple enough I
chose simply learn for its comprehensive
industry relevant curriculum and its
instructors who are industry experts the
instructors were extremely knowledgeable
in their field and made it easy to
understand the complex Concepts the
projects after every module helped me
gain a lot of practical knowledge and
after the course I got what I wanted I
landed a job as far away developer in
leading media giant the carried boot
camp helped me with all my preparation
it prepared me for the interviews and I
landed this new my biggest takeaway is
that I have learned a lot about data
science especially data visualization I
am going to use these skills to climb
the corporate ladder simply learn help
me to Kickstart My Career in data
science and I'm glad that I made the
right direction to upskill myself I will
definitely recommend this course to
those who are willing to pursue their
careers in data science